I want to continue in Volume 4 and taking up at September the 2nd, 1901, and the heading
is that only through the cross will the church re-acquire her full vigour. In other words,
all that has gone wrong, right from the very beginning of 1900, nothing will purify the
church unless she goes through a very deep purification.
Louisa says, "This morning my adorable Jesus made himself seen united with our God and
Holy Father." Oh, sorry. "This morning my adorable Jesus made himself seen united with
the Holy Father." She's talking about the Pope, and the Pope is Leo XIII. He was Pope
until 1902. And Jesus seemed to say to the Pope, "The things suffered up to now are
nothing other than everything I went through from the beginning of my passion until I was
condemned to death." "My son, there's nothing left for you but to carry the cross to Calvary."
So he's telling Pope Leo XIII that he has experienced what Jesus went through in his
ministry and what is required now is for him also to experience the passion. And as he
was saying this, it seemed that blessed Jesus took the cross and placed it upon the shoulders
of the Pope, Leo XIII, helping him to carry it himself. So Jesus helped the Pope to carry
the cross as Jesus himself needed help to have his cross carried in the end. While doing
this, Jesus added, "My church seems to be dying, especially with regard to the social
conditions which anxiously await for the cry of death." So what he's saying is what's
going on socially, that's all this communism and Marxist atheism and all the rest that's
going on. They're crying out for the death of the church. We've already had messages
in which Louisa was shown that the enemies of the church were crying for her death. And
of course 1901 were building up to the Bolshevik Revolution in 1917 in which the church in
Russia and in the states that became the USSR did experience a terrifying death. But of
course they had the resurrection later. So as far as the social conditions are concerned
they're anxiously awaiting the cry of death. "But courage, my son," Jesus said. "After
you have reached the top of the mountain, as the crosses lifted up, all will be shaken
and the church will lay down her aspect of a dying one and will re-acquire her full vigor."
So she will re-acquire her full vigor after a passion death experience. So she will have
her resurrection. "The cross alone is the means for this revival of the church. Just
as the cross alone was the only means to fill the void which sin had made and to unite the
abyss of infinite distance that existed between God and man." So the cross is the bridge that
Jesus has put over the abyss that separated God and man. And we have to walk over the
cross to get to the other side. In the same way, in these times the cross alone will make
my churches forehead rise with courage and splendor so as to confuse and put to flight
the enemies. Now the enemies are the communists and the Marxists, atheists and the materialists
and the unbelievers of all kinds. So having said this, Jesus disappeared. And after a while
he came back all afflicted and he said, "My daughter, how much I grieve for a present
society. They are my members. All members of the body of Christ. That's 1 Corinthians
12. They are my members and I cannot help loving them. It happens to me, it's the same
with me as to one who had one arm or one hand infected or wounded. And do they perhaps hate
it? Do they abhor it? Of course, not because it's your hand or your arm." So on the country
he lavishes all his care upon it and who knows how much he spends to see himself cured. And
it causes his whole body to ache and be oppressed until he manages to obtain the intent of seeing
himself healed. "Such is my condition. I see my members." That's the members of the
church, the members of the mystical body. Okay? So it won't be any harm to write members
of the mystical body of Christ there. So Jesus says, "He sees the members of the mystical
body of Christ infected and wounded." And he said, "I feel pain and sorrow and because
of this I feel more drawn to love them." Oh, how very different is my love from that
of other human creatures. I am forced to love them because they are my own, but they do
not love me as their own. And if they love me at all, if they love me for their own good.
And after this he disappeared and I found myself, Louisa, set inside of myself. So Jesus is
here reflecting on the different ways in which people actually relate to God. We all belong
to him because we all came from him. Jesus took all human beings into himself in his
incarnation and he put all human beings into the cross in his dying so that we can all
be redeemed no matter who we are, who we are, what age we are, what country, what color,
what religion. It doesn't matter. If we come to him, we can be redeemed and saved. And
so when he sees part of the church in a desperate situation, he describes it as like having
your hand or your arm infected and you'll do anything to try and bring healing. And
he says that some of the people, of course, may say they love God, but actually, you know,
they're only interested in maybe saving their own souls or getting some advantage out of
the church or whatever. It's not real love. So September the 4th, 1901, this is one of
the passages that gives us a key. There's lots of keys in these texts which will be good
to study at some point where here Jesus says that gratitude is the key to open the treasures
of God. As my adorable Jesus continued to come this morning, as I saw him, I felt such
a yearning to ask him whether he had forgiven my sins. And so I said to him, my sweet love,
how I yearn to hear from, to hear from your lips, whether you have forgiven me my sins,
of course she has heard the words of absolution from the priest many times. Jesus drew close
to my ear and with his gaze, he seemed to scrutinize all of my interior. And then he
told me, everything is forgiven and I remit them. So Jesus is speaking to her as the high
priest. There's nothing left in you but a few defects committed by you in passing without
realizing it and I remit those as well. So here you've got the generous mercy that Nehemiah
9 17 speaks about and two chronicles 30 verse 7 and Sam 103 verse 8, he treats us very tenderly
like a father treats his children and he knows that we're made of dust. After this it seemed
that Jesus placed himself behind my shoulders, Louisa said, and touching my back with his
hand, he fortified it thoroughly. Who can say what I felt by that touch? I can only say
that I felt a refreshing fire, a purity united to fortitude. So what he's doing is giving
her inner strength for her soul. And then after he touched my back, I prayed him to do the
same with my heart and Jesus to content me condescended to do it. Afterwards it seemed
to me as if blessed Jesus was tired because of me and I said to him, my sweet life, you
are tired because of me, aren't you? And he said, yes, at least be grateful for the
graces that I'm giving you because gratitude is the key to be able to open as one pleases
the treasures that God contains. Gratitude is the key. Now when you go to the miracles
of Jesus in the gospels, and I'm thinking particularly now of the raising of Lazarus
in John chapter 11, that Jesus' prayer began with gratitude, Father, I thank you that you
always hear me. And then he went on and worked in a astounding miracle. So Jesus said, know
however, that what I did to you will serve to preserve you from corruption, to strengthen
you and to dispose your soul and body for eternal glory. Wow. So here we're being told
that we can ask the Lord to preserve us from corruption. And there is so much corruption
in our society, it's saturated with corruption, that it is actually survival stuff to ask
the Lord to protect us from this corruption and to strengthen us and to dispose us to
be able to give ourselves to him thoroughly now and forever. So the next paragraph is
about voids that need to be filled. It's good to write that as a heading.
After this, Louisa said, Jesus seemed to transport me outside of myself, and he made
me see the multitude of people. We would say at multitude of people and the good which
they can do and don't do. And therefore the glory which God must receive and doesn't
receive. All afflicted Jesus said to me, my beloved, my heart burns for the honor and
glory for the honor of my glory and for the good of souls. For each good they omit my
glory and their souls receive a void. These are the sins of omission. Okay. They're the
sins we don't really think about and probably land us all in purgatory more deeply than
we could think. Even if they do know evil, they're not doing the good that they could
do. And they are like those empty rooms which though they're beautiful contain nothing to
be admired and nothing which would strike one's gaze. And therefore their owner receives
no glory. If then they do one good and elect another. They are like those rooms all vacations
in which one can see just a few objects but no particular order. My beloved, come and
take part in these pains in the arteries in which my heart feels for the glory of the
divine majesty and for the good of souls and try to fill these voids. Now this is the substitution
that the Lord asks us to make for others. To enable them to be saved. He said, come and
fill these voids. You can do this by letting not a single moment of your life pass without
being united to my life. That is in all of your actions be they prayer or suffering rest
or work, silence or conversation, sadness or joy or even in the food you take. In some
in everything that may happen to you, you will place the intention. Now this is extremely
important. We need to really underline the importance of placing the intention. Okay,
you must place the intention of giving me all the glory which others should give me in
that action and of making up for the good that they should do but don't do. Intending
to repeat this intention for as much glory as I do not receive and that's actually very
very important. If you do this, you will somehow fill the void of the glory which I must receive
from others and my heart will feel a refreshment from my orders. And from this refreshment,
I feel it's a grace will flow out for the good of others which will infuse in them more
fortitude to do good. And then Louisa said she found herself back inside of herself.
Now what we've just read is something you really need to give attention to and you need
to respond to as well. So September the 5th 1901, we're talking about true love. Now notice
how frequently we're talking about love because the summary of the 36 volumes is divine will
and love. So God is love one John four seven to seventeen. As my beloved Jesus came back,
Louisa said, I felt almost a fear of not corresponding to the graces that the Lord gives me as those
words which he had said to me before, at least be grateful. And this is very important because
Jesus identifies the human race as the ungrateful ones, the ones who just never come back to
give thanks. Do you remember the healing of the ten lepers and only one came back to
give thanks and Jesus said, where are the other nine? Well, it's the same with the human
race. 90% of them are ungrateful for what anybody does for them. So he said to me, at
least be grateful. But that remained impressed on me. Seeing me with this fear, Jesus told
me, my daughter courage do not fear. Love will make up for everything. This is very important.
Besides, since you have placed your will to truly do what I want, even if sometimes you
should fail, I will make up for you. You remember the little rule that Tony Hickey gave us? You
desire it. I'll do it for you. Okay. So if you truly want to do what I want, if you truly
want the divine will, okay? Even if sometimes you fail, Jesus said, I will make up for you,
therefore don't fear. No, however, that true love is ingenious and true ingenuity reaches
everything. More so when in the soul, there is a love that loves. That's number one, a
love that grieves number two, that grieves for the pains of the beloved as if they were
their own. And number three, a love that reaches the point of taking upon itself the sufferings
which the beloved should suffer. Now the first one, you have the interflow of love from the
beloved anti-spouse. Okay. That's the love that loves. And in our prayer and in our private
communion with God, this should be the love that loves all the time. Okay. And then the
second one is the love that grieves over the pains of the beloved. That Louisa looking
at all that Jesus suffers from the sins of human beings and all that we see that he suffers
when we meditate on his passion as well. And a love that the third one is a love that reaches
the point of taking upon itself the sufferings that the beloved should suffer. And therefore,
the third one is that the person is willing to suffer in order to relieve the one you
love, which is Jesus, and to save souls. Okay. So we can never tell God we love him if we're
not interested in saving souls, because that's what he's interested in. And Jesus says that
the love that reaches the point of taking upon itself, the sufferings of the beloved,
this is the most heroic love and the one that resembles his love the most. It's very difficult
to find anyone who lays down his own flesh. Remember Jesus said, "Greater love than this
no man had that to lay down his life for his friends." And I think that's John chapter 10.
If you do not, so if in all of yourself, there is nothing but love, if you do not satisfy
me in one way, you'll do it in another. In other words, if love has taken over the running
of your life, it will manifest itself in many, many different ways, even more. If you are
in possession of these three loves, it will, it's the same to me as to a person who is
insulted and offended with all sorts of outrageous by everyone. But among the many, there is one
who loves him, who sympathizes with him and repays him for all. What does he do? He fixes
his gazes, his beloved, and finding his recompense, he forgets all the offenses and gives favors
and graces to the very offenders themselves. Now in John 17, you find that Jesus as the
high priest actually prays for everyone, but he says something very interesting. I'm actually
not praying for the world, I'm praying for the apostles, I'm praying for my disciples.
And it seems as if, you know, he's the savior of the whole world and he has died for everyone.
So why would you say I'm not praying for the world? He wanted to concentrate all his gifts
and all his graces upon the 12th, that would be the 11 plus Matthias. And because if they
got it right, then the world was going to be okay. If the church gets it right, the world
will be okay. If the church gets it wrong and the church goes into darkness and sin,
then the world goes completely astray, because the world does not realize that it gets all
its energy and all its grace through the church. It just doesn't realize it. And the
church is the 11 in the doe of society. And if the 11 is wrong, the doe will never ever
make bread. So September 9, 1901, again, this is a very important message about the effectiveness
of our intentions. So we have to absolutely make sure that we tell the Lord what we intend
to do. This morning, my adorable Jesus was not coming. And then while my mind was occupied
with considering the mystery of the crowning of thorns, I remembered that at other times,
as I was occupied with this mystery, the Lord had pleased to remove the crown of thorns
from his head and to drive it into mine. So I said in my interior, "A Lord, I'm no longer
worthy of suffering your thorns." And all of a sudden he came for just a little and he
told me, "My daughter, when you suffer my own thorns, you relieve me. And in suffering
them yourself, I feel completely free of those pains." Isn't that absolutely incredible?
So when she takes the crown of thorns, it relieves him completely of the pains that he's getting
from the sins that are coming at him, okay? "When you humble yourself and believe yourself
unworthy of suffering them, you repair for the sins of pride." Wow. Isn't that fantastic?
And these sins of pride, of course, are the greatest sins that are committed in the world.
We said, "Lord, for as many drops of blood understood that you shed, for as many thorns
as you suffered, for as many wounds so much glory do I intend to give you, for as much
glory as all creatures should give you if the sin of pride did not exist. And so, so
many graces do I intend to ask of you for all creatures so that this sin be destroyed."
So it's a prayer to destroy pride. Now, if you ever came across an important prayer,
you have it now. Because pride is the thing that keeps everybody away from God. It is
the biggest barrier. It's the first and greatest of the deadly sins. It's the sin that makes
us most like Satan. So I want to give you Galatians 6, 17, where Paul says, "I make
up for what is wanting in the body of Christ." So Paul was talking about suffering as well.
So while saying this, Louisa saw that Jesus contained the whole world within himself because
it's his creation, like a machine containing objects in itself. All creatures moved within
him. So I want to just remind you of Ephesians chapter 1, Colossians chapter 1, John 1,
1 to 5. They're all talking about he is everything and everything was made in him and through
him and for him. He is everything. All creatures moved within him and Jesus moved towards them.
Now notice within him and he moved towards them. And it seemed that Jesus would receive
the glory of my intention. Now what she's looking at is the result of her prayer. Okay.
So it would be good to put a little heading here. You first of all have this prayer and
then you have the result of the prayer. And you see Jesus lets her see it visually so
that she can explain it to us in a way that we can actually understand. So let me go back.
All creatures moved within Jesus and Jesus moved towards them as Louisa was praying this
prayer to bring down pride. And of course the prayer to bring down pride you need Isaiah
chapter 2 and it's verses 7, 9, 11 and so on where Isaiah says that the pride of man must
be brought low if God is to be glorified and if God's will is to be done on earth. So all
the creatures moved within Jesus as she was praying and he moved towards them. And it seemed
that Jesus would receive the glory of my intention that creatures had returned to him in order
to receive the good impetrated by me for them. I remain stupefied and he's seeing my reaction
said all this seems surprising doesn't it? What you have done seems a trivial thing but
it is not so. How much good could be done by repeating this intention but it is not.
So having said it this he disappeared. This is why it's important for us if we do this
prayer that Louisa has just done that we say to the Lord I want to multiply this intention
to infinity to cover all creatures all times all places all conditions so that you do in
fact bring the pride of man low at some point because saying it once is not going to do
anything well not anything significant anyway. Just think if you want to water your garden
and only one drop of rain falls on it it's not going to water the garden you need a proper
shower to drench the garden and then the flowers all come up absolutely thrilled with this
amount of life giving substance that's given to them. In the same way a shower of our acts
needs to be given as well so we need to say to the Lord I multiply this act and this intention
to infinity okay so it's good actually to write that down so is to multiply your prayers
to infinity. Infinity to cover all times all situations all conditions forever so that
everybody's covered is to make absolutely sure and of course you do it in the divine
will the multiplication won't happen outside of the divine will it'll only happen within
it because it's only in the divine will that everything is possible and so that reminds
you of what Jesus said to in the gospel that everything is possible with God and so if
you've any doubts about this just write it down everything is possible with God. Now I
I stopped for a moment to let you actually write it to make sure you have it with you.
So September the 10th 1901 is another very important message to unite our actions with
Jesus it means to continue his life on earth. Now if we only offer our actions to Jesus
they're worth nothing. I mean who are we? Jesus told Louise that she was only a national
incredible. So if we're only the size of a national that means you need an electron
microscope to see us. Then our little act has that value. If you want to increase that
act what you do is you unite it with the same act in Jesus life I'm presuming it's a good
act and therefore you take on his infinite merits and his infinite graces. Now your act
is big. Now you have become an ocean and if you put that into the divine will then it
has become infinite. Now you're at the level where your act actually makes a difference
to everybody. So Louise says I continue to do what blessed Jesus taught me on the fourth
of this month. So that goes back three messages passed even though sometimes I get distracted
she says. But when sometimes I forget it seems that Jesus places himself on guard in my interior.
Now notice that he is watching all the time and that he is guiding her all the time so
I want to give you a jute around him a 32 12 the Lord alone was her guide. So he places
himself on guard in my interior and does it himself for me. That's what he says if you
desire it I will do it. There it is illustrated for you. So on seeing this I blush and immediately
I unite myself with him we call that fusing you fuse yourself in him and I make the offering
of what I am doing at that moment but even a gaze or a word and I keep saying Lord all
for your glory. Now we need to say this to him hundreds of times a day all for your glory
which creatures should give you with their mouths but do not I intend to do with my mouth
and I intercede for them to make good the holy use of the mouth by uniting myself always
with the very mouth of Jesus. Now while I was doing this she said in all my things Jesus
came and said this is the continuation of my life while she was doing this. Okay this
is the continuation of my life she said which was for the glory of the father and the good
of souls. Now I can't give you a reference because I'd have to give you the whole of John's gospel.
If you persevere in this he said you will form my life and I yours and you will be my breath
and I yours and this is incredible because the breath of God is the Holy Spirit. Rulok, R-U-A-C-H
Adonai, A-D-O-N-I-A the very breath of God and then the name they eventually called Yahweh
is my breath. Yah! My out breath and my in breath. So Yahweh is my very breath and that's what Jesus
is saying here. You will be my breath and I will be yours. I find that totally astonishing.
The only comment I have in my own margin is well. After this Jesus placed himself in order
to rest in my heart and I upon his heart and it seemed that Jesus would draw his breath from me
and I would draw mine from his. What happiness, what joy, what celestial life I experienced. Now notice
what celestial life I experienced in that position, she said. May the Lord be always
thanked and blessed who uses so many mercies on this sinner. So I want to give you John 14 20 to 21,
you in me and I in you both completely one and Galatians 220 I no longer live Christ lives in me.
So now I go on to September the 14th 1901 and I have a VIP on this one as well and again we're
back to talking about love letting you see that love is completely central to the whole thing.
After going through various days of privation Louisa said today as I was about to do my meditation
my mind was distracted in something else and by means of a light that's infused knowledge
I understood that in going out of the body the soul enters into God but since God is most pure love
only when the soul is a complex of love is she able to enter into God.
Now we've said this before and I have to keep repeating it because it's all over these writings
and going to God either in prayer or in death the only baggage allowed is love and God is love.
So if you take negative baggage into prayer you'll find your prayer completely impossible.
It just won't work. You've got to get rid of the negative baggage.
Many many years ago I'm talking at least 40 to 45 years ago when I used to lead a prayer meeting
in Black Rock County Dublin. I used to say to everybody we had about 120 people in that prayer
meeting I used to say to them leave your problems outside the door you come in and then we'll start
praising God and because we decided to leave our problems outside the door and come in and praise
God the praise used to take off like a rocket it was absolutely unbelievable because we discovered
that if you came in and you tried to praise God with the weight of the problems you'd carried in
you weren't going to get anywhere otherwise you're going to have to spend all the time
solving these problems and we'd say no no no we deal with your problems when it's all over
we give God the glory first and we love him first and we praise him and adore him and learn from
him and absolutely everything afterwards then we'll deal with whatever sores and wounds you have
and it always worked a treat. So Louisa says that when the soul goes out of the body and enters into
God God is most pure love now you know that pure means not mixed with anything else.
So this is this is love at a level that we don't understand so only when the soul is a complex
of love that means love in many many different shades does she is she even able to enter into
God. In fact God receives no one into himself if she's not completely similar to him now really
you'd have to underline that in green white and gold and put Hebrews 1214 beside it.
There's also a text in Revelation 21 where they describe 21 and 22 where they describe the new
Jerusalem where everybody is living in the divine will and anyone outside of the divine will
is not even allowed to enter the city. Okay so in fact God receives no one into himself if she's
not completely similar to him so I also want to give you there one John three two and that is
that someone who is truly living in God is not living a sin life if you're living a sin life you're
not living in God forget about it. And on finding the soul similar to him he receives her as the
soul is always spoken of in the feminine because where the where the spouse and the Lord is the
the bridegroom he receives her and shares all of his qualities with her. Now you'll see this when
you go into the book of Revelation chapters two and three where John is told by the Holy Spirit
to tell everybody that if you overcome this problem and that problem and the other problem
you can share God's throne you can share his crown you can share his glory you can share
everything it's amazing. So we shall be in God so we shall be in God beyond the heavens
just as we are inside our rooms here. Now it seems to me that this could be done also during the
course of our lives so as to spare the fire of purgatory the toil. I love the way she says
spare the fire of purgatory the toil not save you the pain and she oh she does add and ourselves
the pain and therefore be introduced immediately without any interruption into our highest good
who is God. It seems to me that the nourishment of fire is wood and the sign to be sure
that the wood is reduced to fire is that it no longer produces smoke. Now the beginning and the
end of all our actions must be fire the fire of the love of God. The wood which must nourish the
fire are the crosses the mortifications the smoke that rises in the midst of the wood and the fire
are the passions the inclinations which often peep out. So the sign that everything is consumed
by the fire within us is that our passions remain in their place so she gives you a sign.
Okay so circle sign and mark passions. The sign is that the passions are pacified they're not
screaming and roaring at you and we no longer feel the inclination towards all that does not regard
God. It seems that with this we will pass freely with no obstacle to dwell inside of our God
and we will come to enjoy even here below paradise on earth. In other words the same as before the
fall. So let's come back a little bit. There's a wonderful text in Matthew 3 from verse 11 it might
be 11 and 12 where he says that Jesus has come to baptize us with the Holy Spirit and fire.
That's the fire of God's love and he said and then he goes on to say in verse 12 that
if you don't accept this fire of love to purify you then you'll have to be thrown on the fire that
never goes out. So I thought that's interesting there's two fires so let's look at them for a minute
there's two fires. The image of God is fire you get that from Sinai our God is a consuming fire.
The image of hell is fire as well. That's the amazing thing it's the exact opposite of God.
The image of purgatory is fire. Fire is also given as an image of war it's given as an image of
chastisement it's given as an image of illness or trouble or tribulation of any kind. So fire is
multiple symbol but let's take fire as a symbol of heaven and hell. As a symbol of heaven it's a
symbol of love. As a symbol of hell it's a symbol of hate and love and hate are two sides of one coin.
So let's look at what the fire of love does. When the fire of love comes into us it does four
things. It cleanses, sanctifies, sorry it cleanses, purifies, sanctifies and glorifies.
Cleanses is the first stage after we have committed ourselves to the Lord. It's the first stage after
conversion. Purification is much much deeper. Cleansing is a bit like you pull up the weeds
but you haven't pulled up all the roots and so you've got to go back next week and get the next
layer of weeds that have come up because the roots were alive. That's like somebody going to
confession and they're confessing the same thing over and over and over again. They've not pulled
up the roots. So cleansing has got to be followed by purifying that means you pull up the weeds
by the roots and then you don't have weeds. You pull up the sins by the roots and therefore you
don't have sins. Therefore this is followed by sanctifying. That means we're brought into union
with God and since God is pure and holy and love and sanctity and all the rest of it we have to be
made like that to be one with God and when we're made like that then when it comes to our death
he glorifies us. We reach the fullness that is intended for our being so the process is that love
cleanses, cleanses love purifies, love sanctifies and love glorifies. Now if we don't allow this
process because that's the process of redemption. If we don't allow it to happen then it means that
we have to be thrown on the inert fire of hell. That's a fire of hatred. It's not love. So of
course it will never cleanse. It will never purify. It will never sanctify and of course never glorify.
So inhale your problems get worse. In heaven all your virtues get better. A completely different
thing and yet the same image is used of both which is fire which is very important. So there's an
offer more could be said about that but we have to go on. September the 15th 1901 by shunning the
cross you have to remain in the dark. Now Louisa tells us very clearly that when Jesus took up the
cross on his way to Calvary that he assigned a place in the cross for each one of us and that
place in the cross is essential for us to actually reach where God wants to bring us. That's his
absolute essential. If we refuse to let the cross do this work in us and that's the work of cleansing
and purifying and sanctifying. If we don't let that happen then we have to remain unredeemed.
We've simply just not allowed it. That's like saying there's a medical system in the country.
There's thousands of doctors and nurses in the country but I refuse to go to a doctor when there's
something wrong with me. So it's not their fault that I die of the illness that I have. I made the
decision not to go to a doctor. I made the decision to take no medical care. I made the decision not
to do anything about the problem that's within me. Therefore what happens is entirely my own fault.
It's exactly the same on a spiritual level. The Redeemer came. He redeemed us of everything.
He paid for absolutely everything but if I'm so spiritually lazy that I will not do anything
to reach out for that grace and that sanctification and that redemption that was given to me then it's
not his fault that I'm not redeemed. It's mine. Mine entirely. And so the people who land themselves
in hell have not one excuse before God, not one. So this is September the 15th 1901.
This morning my adorable Jesus came all glorious with his wounds like refulgent suns. It's absolutely
wonderful. You know this and there's the image of the divine mercy as well. The extraordinary
light coming from all the wounds of Jesus and Saint Margaret Mary got that image as well.
So his wounds were like refulgent suns with a cross in his hand.
In the meantime I saw a wheel with four sections so she sees a wheel with four sections of it leaning
out while it seemed that another section shunned the light and remained in the dark. In this darkening
the people remained as though abandoned by God. Okay and bloody wars would happen against the
church and against themselves. That seemed that the things said by blessed Jesus in the past are
approaching at a fast pace. See it's 1901 and the things that are approaching at a fast pace of course
was World War I. The Bolshevik Revolution, the terrifying martyrdom of the church in the USSR.
Now on seeing all this move to compassion our Lord drew near the dark part and he cast
the cross he had in his hand upon it saying with the sonorous voice glory to the cross Galatians
614. I gloryed the cross of our Lord Jesus Christ by whom he was crucified for me and I for him.
Glory to the cross and it seemed that that cross would call back the light and the people
so stirring themselves they would implore help and aid so it brought them out of the spiritual
darkness they were in and into enough light for them to be able to call upon God for help.
So Jesus repeated all the glory and triumph will be with the cross one Corinthians 118.
Otherwise the remedies will make the very evils worse sometimes the cure is worse than the disease.
Therefore he said the cross the cross who could say how afflicted I felt and concerned for what
might happen. So I want to give you one Corinthians 1 17 to 25 where Paul talks about the language
of the cross means nothing to worldly people but to those who have learned its language it is of
course the greatest wisdom from heaven. So October the second 1901 Jesus takes Louisa to heaven and
the angels ask him to show her to the people okay so she now has a heaven experience.
This morning my adorable Jesus came and transported me outside of myself in the midst of people.
Who can tell what evils and horrors could be seen now that's your usual Amos 3 7
and Isaiah 64 10.
And also Jeremiah saying to Hananiah you know have you been in the council of God.
Who can tell the evils and horrors that could be seen then all afflicted Jesus told me my daughter
what a stench emanates from the earth is the stench of sin. It was supposed to be one united
with heaven and since in heaven they do nothing but love me and praise me and thank me the echo
of heaven was to absorb the earth to form a united thing but the earth has rendered itself
unbearable you'll find that in Revelation 14. Therefore come she said and unite yourself with
heaven and in the name of all come to give me a satisfaction for them. Now a satisfaction is
usually reparation. In one instance I found myself amidst the angels and saints I'm unable to say
how but I felt an infusion in me of what the angels and saints were singing and saying
and I like them did my part in the name of the whole earth. So here she is in the council of God
and you really need to look that up because in Jeremiah he says that if a person has not
been in the council of God they're not a true prophet. So here she is.
And after this all content my sweet Jesus said addressing everyone behold an angelic note from
the earth how satisfied I feel. Okay so that reminds me of the song of songs I think it's chapter 7
who is this coming up from the earth and she's like an army in battle array she has so much power.
Behold an angelic voice or note from the earth and while saying this almost to repay me he took
me in his arms he kissed me and kissed me over and over again showing me off to the whole court of
heaven as an object of his dearest satisfactions. On seeing this the angel said Lord we pray you
show the people what you have operated in this soul. With a prodigious sign of your omnipotence
for the glory and for the good of souls. No longer keep the treasures poured in her hidden so that
as they themselves would see and touch your omnipotence in another person this might cause
an improvement for those who are evil and of greater spur to those who want to do good. So as soon as the
angels and saints have Luisa pointed out to them as the angelic note from the earth the angels
actually intercede. Now this is very very interesting because throughout the scriptures it's the
angel to do God's will. The angels go to Abraham to tell him whatever they have to tell him in
Genesis 18. It's the angel who come to various people all along the way and it's the angel who
comes to blessed mother. It's the angels who carry out the chastisements of the Lord in in the book
of Revelation. Now I could go on and on about that but you've got the idea. The angels do it and
here you have the angels saying to Jesus listen would you ever make known to the world what you've
done in this soul because some of them will improve and others who are really looking for you they
might take on this life. So what they do is they intercede for the era of the divine will to begin
which I think is wonderful. On hearing this I felt myself in court by fear Luisa said and annihilating
myself completely. That means going into my nothingness okay and the nothingness is the safe place on
earth. Going into my nothings she said to the point I saw myself like a tiny little fish I threw
myself into the heart of Jesus saying Lord I want nothing but you and to be hidden in you this is
what I have always asked of you and this is what I pray you to confirm in me. So I want to give you
Philippians 3 8 to 11 there. So having said this Luisa said I enclosed myself in the interior of
Jesus as though swimming in the most extensive sea of the interior of God that is the sea of the
divine will and then Jesus said to everyone have you heard that she wants nothing but me and to be
hidden in me this is her greatest contentment which of course is the experience of heaven that's
what heaven is and I on seeing an intention so pure feel more drawn to her and seeing her
displeasure if I were to show my work to the people with the prodigious sign so as not to
saddened her will not concede to what you have asked for me. So here is the very delicate response
that Jesus gives to the angels that because Luisa wants so badly to be hidden and absolute nobody
he says to them now I can't make a prodigious sign for you it would really upset her and I'm
not going to upset her and so you get a taste of what it's like to be inside of the divine will
and to live the divine will means to live in the heart of God and notice that Jesus defends her
and protects her it seemed that the angels were insisting but I didn't pay attention to anyone
anymore I love that the angels were insisting on everything now when Luisa pays no attention to
the angels you've got to remember Mary of Magdula on Easter day John chapter 20 verses 1 to 10
the angels communicate to her the fact of the resurrection she pays no attention just says
where's Jesus where's the body you just tell me where he is and I'll get him she pays no attention
to the fact that she couldn't lift a dead body if she thinks it's dead and it pays no attention
to anyone she is the lover who wants her beloved and that's just simply that so
Luisa says I'm not paying attention to any of them I'm safely inside of the heart of Jesus and that's
it that's where I'm staying and so she said I did nothing but swim in God to understand the divine
interior isn't that absolutely incredible but no I seemed to be like a little child who wants to
clasp with his little hand an object of immeasurable magnitude such that as he grabs it it escapes from
him and he can barely manage to touch it now what that reminds me of is a small child trying to
capture a sunbeam in their their hands and when they open the hand the sunbeam isn't there and
they keep on grabbing this beautiful sunbeam and they can't get hold of it so the child is unable
to tell either how much it weighs or how large that that object is or like another child who not
knowing all the depth of studies says with yearning that he must learn everything in a short time
but he can barely manage to learn the first letters of the alphabet in the same way the soul can say
nothing but this I've touched it it is beautiful it's great there's no good that it does not possess
it won't give you two Corinthians 12 there that describes Paul's experience in heaven where he says
I don't know whether I was in the body or out of the body these things are too great to be able to
speak about and one Corinthians two nine as well the eye cannot see nor the ear understand or the
heart grasp the great things that God has prepared for us so she said you can't say anything how much
how much greatness does it contain how many goods does it possess you I'm unable to tell
that is of God she can tell the first letters of the alphabet leaving the whole depth of studies
behind so I want to give you Ephesians three verses 16 to 21 there that in order to grow in
understanding of who God is we have to be grounded in love and grow in love and be perfected in love
as Louisa is experiencing herself so she continues even in heaven my dearest brothers angels and
saints being creatures do not have the capacity of understanding their creator in everything of
course because they're finite and he's infinite they are like many containers of different sizes
filled with God which if who wants to fill them anymore they flow outside I believe I'm speaking
much nonsense what she's actually trying to do is give us an image which is actually quite a good
image if you take a bath and fill it and you put a cup into it and you put a jug into it and you
put a whole whole other glasses drinking glasses into it they're all filled and the water is way
over them but they're not holding the bath of water it's not possible they can only hold what
is contained within themselves and so while people are in God and they're overflowing to their own
capacity it's nothing at all to what is actually available and this is actually very important
okay so I'll give you one more October the 3rd 1901 this is Ivan also a VIP on this one as well
the Weezer offers herself in a special way there's no greater obstacle to the union of God
than the human will oh dear we have to really take care of the human will if anything keeps you
out of heaven it's your human will if anything sends you to purgatory it's your human will if
anything sends you to hell it'll be your human will so Louisa says having received communion
I was thinking of how to offer something more special to Jesus how to prove my love and to give
him more pleasure so I said to him my most beloved Jesus I offer you my heart for your satisfaction
and in eternal praise to you I offer you all of myself even the tiniest particles of my body
like as many walls to be placed before you in order to block any offense that might be given
to you accepting them all upon myself if it were possible and for your pleasure until the day of
judgment my goodness and since I want my offering to be complete now notice that she is doing the
I want thing this is placing the intention so please put that as a heading above this this is
very important and since I want my offering to be complete and to satisfy you for everyone I intend
for all the pains which I will bear by receiving upon myself the offense is given to you to repay
you with all the glory with which the saints who are in heaven were supposed to give you when
they were on the earth isn't it amazing to make up for all that the saints were not able to do
we're inclined to think the saints did everything
I want to repay you for that which the souls and purgatory were supposed to give you
and that glory which all human beings past present and future owe you I offer them all to you
for all in general and for each one in particular as I finished speaking Louisa said all moved by
this offering blessed Jesus told me my by beloved you yourself cannot understand the great contentment
you've given to me by offering yourself in this way you've suited all my wounds and you've given me
satisfaction for all offenses past present and future and I will take it into account for all
eternity like a most precious gem which will glorify me eternally and every time I will look at it I
will give you new and greater eternal glory my daughter there is no greater obstacle which prevents
the union between souls and myself and that which is more opposed to my grace than one's own will
put a VIP beside that will you go back and look at it over and over again
you by offering me your heart for my satisfaction have emptied yourself of yourself
and because of your emptying yourself of yourself I will pour all of myself into you
and from your heart a praise will come to me which will carry the same notes as the praise that my
heart gives to the father continuously to satisfy satisfy for the glory that men do not give him
so again put a heading on the the next paragraph which we're going to finish with now and that is
the importance of placing the intention while he was saying this I saw that by means of my
offering many rivelets were coming out of every part of me which poured over blessed Jesus who
then with impetus and greater abundance poured them over the whole celestial court over purgatory
and over all people or goodness of my Jesus in accepting such a meager offering and reciting
it with so much grace or prodigy of the holy and pious intentions if in all our works even trivial
we made use of them what traffic would we not produce how many eternal properties would we not
require how much more glory would we not give to the Lord as an awful lot there that needs to be
considered but I'm going to leave it there for the moment
[BLANK_AUDIO]